aujourd'hui il fait plus frais il y à du
vent je me suis installé dans l'atelier
les éoliennes tournent à plein régime
le vent c'est une circulation d'air
d'une zone de haute pression vers une
zone de basse pression
l'air qui nous entourent chauffé par le
soleil se dilate les molécules qui
composent ces cartes les unes des autres
il est moins dense que l'air froid et sa
pression est plus faible à volume égal
l'air chaud et plus léger que l'air
froid il s'élève dans l'atmosphère et
comme la nature cherche toujours l'
équilibre
l'air froid prend sa place en allant
toujours d'une zone où la pression est
plus forte vers une zone où la pression
est plus faible
c'est ce qui est à l'origine des coups
de vent et de cette nouvelle capsule 2d
confiné en coup de vent allait à demain
et n'oubliez pas nous sommes confinés
mais en restant rien si vous avez aimé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un
pouce bleus gens réalisent une nouvelle
chaque jour alors pour ne rater aucune
de ces capsules 2d confiné abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain